مع الإبلاغ عن المزيد من الحالات في
الشرق الأوسط في هذه الحالات التي يتم تتبعها
إلى الأشخاص الإيرانيين الذين زاروا
البلاد والتي أثبتت إصابتهم بالمرض ،
فهناك قلق متزايد بشأن كيفية
تعامل إيران مع تفشي المرض ، هل يفعلون
ما يكفي لمحاولة احتوائه ، هل هم
قادرون على ذلك  فعل ما يكفي بالنظر إلى
تأثير العقوبات الأمريكية على
الرعاية الصحية في البلاد ومسؤولينا الذين
يتسمون بالشفافية بشأن حجم
هذا التفشي ، المشكلة هنا هي في
الحقيقة الأرقام التي لا تضيف
معدل الوفيات الناجمة عن فيروس كورونا في إيران
في هذه المرحلة.  يكون في مكان ما حوالي 14 إلى
15 في المائة وهو أعلى
بكثير من معدل الوفيات في أي
بلد آخر والمتوسط العالمي لذلك هن
ك مخاوف بشأن سبب حدوث ذل
هناك مشكلة في ال
حص هل يقومون بفحص جميع ال
الات المحتملة هل يظهر الأشخاص ال
عراض  الذهاب إلى المستشفيات أم أن هذه
حالة النظام الإيراني السري الذي
يحاول التقليل من خطورة
الوضع الذي سمعناه  من الرئيس حسن
روحاني يوم الأربعاء محاولا طمأنة
الناس بإخبارهم بأن
الوضع تحت السيطرة وهاجم الولايات
المتحدة قائلا إنها تحاول
بث الخوف والذعر بين
السكان وأن أعداء إيران
على حد تعبيره يحاولون استغلال  هذا
الفيروس كسلاح لتدمير الاقتصاد الإيراني ،
لكن ربما كان البيان الأكثر إثارة للقلق
من الرئيس هو أن
السلطات هناك حتى الآن لم تتخذ الحكومة
هناك قرارًا بفرض الحجر الصحي على
أي مدن إيرانية وهذا
يضغط حقًا على دول
المنطقة المجاورة لدول.  تكثيف
إجراءاتهم الوقائية لمحاولة
منع تفشي هذا المرض أو انتشاره ،
على سبيل المثال سمعنا
من وزير الصحة في تركيا حتى
الآن يقولون إنه ليس لديهم أي حالات
إصابة بفيروس كورونا لكنهم يقولون إنك تعلم
في وقت ما أن
نشر ما يحاولون فعله
الآن هو تأخير انتشار مرض
شبانة كراتشي وسي إن إن اسطنبول
الذي تبحث عنه  عادي جديد
للعديد من مطاعم الوجبات السريعة في الصين ،
يدخل العملاء إلى كنتاكي فرايد تشيكن هذا ويمرون
عبر فحوصات درجة الحرارة القياسية الآن ،
ويصعدون إلى شاشة عملاقة ، حيث
يقومون بنقل طلباتهم من
هواتفهم الذكية ، وبالتالي تجنب
لمس السطح أو كتابته
بمجرد  إنهم يبتعدون
عن إنقضاض أحد الموظفين لتطهير
بعض المتاجر مثل Chung hi Starbucks هذه
يسلب فقط الهدف الذي يمنع الناس من
التجمع.
جلسنا مع الرئيس التنفيذي الصيني الشاب
جوي وات ، تدير شركتها بعضًا من
أشهر العلامات التجارية للأطعمة في الصين
بما في ذلك KFC Taco Bell و Pizza Hut ،
ما أفضل طريقة للتعامل مع
الشدائد هو أن تظل هادئًا لحل Patera
أن الحماية مستمرة خارج
المطاعم  توصيل الطعام أيضًا حول
الحفاظ على مساحتك ، هذا ما يحدث
هنا ، لقد تركوه هناك ، أخبرني أنه
يمكنني الذهاب للتحرك في اختيار  ع الطعام
والعودة إلى المنزل لتناول الطعام وبمجرد حصولك على
طعامك ستلاحظ أعلى
الإيصال أن هذه البطاقة الصغيرة تحتوي على
نوعين مختلفين من القراءات عليها
قراءة درجة حرارة الشخص الذي
أعد طعامك مع
أكد الاسم وقراءة الاسم ودرجة الحرارة
للشخص الذي أوصل طعامك
يوم السبت المسؤولون الصحيون في
ولاية واشنطن أول حالة وفاة في
الولايات المتحدة من فيروس كورونا ،
يقول مركز السيطرة على الأمراض إنها قد تكون حالة انتشار مجتمعي
وليس مخاوف متعلقة بالسفر من
انتشار واسع  يتزايد انتشار تجار التجزئة في جميع أنحاء البلاد
مثل CVS و
Walgreens يقولون إنهم لاحظوا زيادة
الطلب على مناديل تنظيف مطهرات اليد
وأقنعة الوجه - يقول الرئيس ترامب - إنه
سيلتقي بشركات الأدوية
يوم الاثنين للحديث عن تطوير
لقاح يقول إن الإدارة
مستعدة  كميات هائلة من
الإمدادات في متناول اليد بالفعل لدينا 43 مليون
كمامة أكثر بكثير مما كان يمكن أن يفترضه أي شخص
بسرعة ،
يترأس نائب الرئيس مايك بنس
استجابة البيت الأبيض لفيروس كورونا
يوم السبت ، حيث أعلن
عن قيود سفر جديدة على إيران في استشارة
لأجزاء من إيطاليا وكوريا الجنوبية ،
وقد أذن الرئيس اليوم وزارة الخارجية
بزيادة
نصائح السفر للأمريكيين إلى المستوى 4
يحثون الأمريكيين على عدم السفر إلى
المناطق في إيطاليا في المناطق في
كوريا الجنوبية الأكثر تضررًا من
فيروس كورونا ، وتقول مراكز السيطرة على
الأمراض والوقاية منها إن أفضل
طريقة لمكافحة فيروس كورونا هي غسل
يديك جيدًا بالماء والصابون
أنا ميليسا مطيرة أبلغنا
الآن أننا اكتشفنا
حالة قادمة من إيران والتي
أصبحت للأسف واحدة من
البلدان المتضررة ونعتقد أنك
تعلم بسبب هذا التأثير في إيران ،
فلدينا تقريبًا تأثير الآن في المنطقة
ونرى أنه أصبح
فيروس ينتشر على نطاق واسع في العالم بأسره
، لكننا جهزنا كل شيء
لتلقي جميع مرافق الرعاية الصحية
لتلقي الحالات التي كانت لدينا ولكن
مع التأكد أيضًا من عزلها بعيدًا
عن المجتمع وعدم
تأثر البلد بها على نطاق واسع ، ما هو
رأي الحكومة في الوقت الحالي حول مدى
الضرر الذي يمكن أن ينجم عن هذا التأثير
اقتصاديًا عالميًا  كمحور مهم لشركات الطيران ،
ساعدت بلدانهم التي تعرفها في جعل
نفسها وجهة سياحية بالإضافة إلى
ما ترى أن هذا النوع من
التأثيرات على نطاق أوسع ليس فقط على المستوى الإقليمي على
الصعيد العالمي ، ما هو حجم التقييم الذي يمكن أن
يكون هناك بالتأكيد سيكون هناك
تأثير نبدأ  لنرى في
الأيام والأسابيع القليلة الماضية ورأينا
تأثيرًا على الأسواق المالية
رأينا تأثيرًا على سوق السفر على
النفط على كل شيء وجميع الجوانب
ولكننا نعتقد أن هذه ستكون
دورة لأنه  الفيروس نفسه
يحد من السفر في حدود أنه يغلق
الكثير من أماكن العمل الكثير من
المصانع مما يؤثر على
أداء الشركات ولكن هذا لن يستمر إلى
الأبد
أعني بالتأكيد  سيأتي وقت
نرى فيه احتواء الفيروس
وطريقة لهزيمته وسنرى أيضًا
السوق يتصاعد مرة أخرى
[موسيقى]